- Every movie about
alcohol is normally so sad.
- Yeah.
- No one ever shows the upsides.
(dynamic upbeat music)
- Hi, I'm Robert Eggers.
- And I'm Robert Pattinson.
- And this is our "Scene Breakdown" for.
- "The Lighthouse."
(eerie melodic music)
I think it was just water, but
we were drinking it though,
I mean, there was, it was actually,
when I was talking about
this the other day,
it's hard to do that.
- Yeah.
- You literally can't, you
felt disgusting afterwards
and then it's kind of--
- And we did like four takes of that.
- Yeah, yeah, it's
really, really difficult
to swallow like Willem,
I've got a very pronounced gag reflex.
- Yeah, and you guys, yeah.
(eerie melodic music)
♪ Gypsy little whore, hoo rah ♪
♪ I'm done with her, don't let me down ♪
- I mean, there was like
a very specific dance
that we were supposed to be doing,
which you can sort of see Willem doing.
Do you know, I guess I had a
different dance to rehearse,
I had a kind of a lumberjack dance.
- Yeah, but I mean,
you're doing all the moves
around the table with
Willem and everything.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I feel like because my
character is so contained,
constricted and kind of
early in his sobriety,
I kind of wanted to, it
wasn't just when he got drunk,
'cause Willem was drinking the whole time,
it wasn't like they would
end up on the same level.
- [Robert E] Yeah, yeah, right.
- They would just go way beyond,
it's not like it's fun
to hang out with him,
- Yeah.
- literally it's like,
and then when he gets sort
of tender with him later,
when he's kind of tired and drunk,
then it's even more there
and it's like they could never
quite get on the same page,
but I think that's kind
of what I was doing.
- Yeah, that makes total sense, yeah
and because generally things
are so tamped down in here,
the dancing and the drinking
is just like revving you up to 110.
(eerie melodic orchestral music)
- And he's been looking
for Willem's validation the whole movie
and it's kind of as soon as
he's getting his attention
and focus, it's literally like
he's been wanting a pat
on the head for so long,
that as soon as he gets
the attention on him,
it's like a hyperactive child,
like you just completely lose your mind.
- Yeah, yeah and you're definitely trying
to outdo his jig with
your lumberjack dance.
By the way, you can't see Rob's feet,
but the dance he's doing
is incredibly complicated,
Robert Flatley would be very envious.
- I think that's the only time
I've actually successfully
managed to do a spin,
like wow, yeah, whenever
Willem Dafoe shouts, "Dance,"
at you, it is a different,
like normally if someone says
hey, do you wanna have a dance?
It just wouldn't happen.
♪ Dee dee dee dee dee dee
dee dee dee dee dee dee ♪
- Dance!
Dance, Winslow!
Dance!
(thudding)
♪ Come all you boys, do you want to hear ♪
♪ How we got to the woods last year ♪
- Yeah, that's one of my
favorite performances of yours,
I think Rob often surprised me,
this was one of these moments,
where he went further than I expected,
but also slightly different
than what my preconceived
notions about the character.
In the end of this clip,
when you seem like you're
speaking in tongues,
like everyone, the entire crew was shocked
and it's one of the most memorable moments
in the film for me.
Rob is singing, I mean,
he is singing lyrics here,
like if you watch this with subtitles,
like this is a lumberjack song.
♪ Come all you boys, do you want to hear ♪
♪ How we got to the woods last year ♪
(garbled singing)
- It's kind of hard, 'cause
I knew it was in the script,
it was he's speeding up and
speeding up and speeding up,
I think that's like
three verses of the song.
- Yeah, yeah and the
recording that you had
was like a trillion times slower,
- Yeah, yeah.
- than you were doing it.
- Right, it was fun.
- Like this scene shows
you are so extreme.
Right before this is a montage
of masturbating with
lots of horror imagery
and severed heads.
- Just before that, yeah.
- And my brother and Jarin Blaschke,
my brother, who wrote this with me
and Jarin Blaschke, the DP,
we were like okay, so this dancing scene
needs to be scarier than a severed head
and I think you nailed it.
- Yes.
(eerie melodic orchestral music)
There's hardly any movie or any characters
or any character arcs, where
you could have that sustained,
heightened desperation for
nine and a half minutes,
it was kind of fun.
- Yeah, yeah, totally.
- And plus being absolutely
obliterated drunk,
I don't know how many movies
are gonna come out like that again.
Thanks for watching us,
see you in "Breakdown"
and be sure to check out "The Lighthouse,"
it's in theaters right now.
- And buy your tickets on Fandango.
- Woo, woo, woo!
(light melodic music)